Oh honored walk walk is lon lon gene
watches have 110 World's Fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece lon gene the world's most
honored watch is made in guaranteed by
the lawn gene with no watch company it's
time for the launching Chronister the
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the American
mercury and mr. Donald I Rogers an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is general john s would former chief of
mission of the international refugee
organization the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speaker's
general Lord a great many GIS will
remember you as the courageous commander
of the 4th Armored Division which slept
across France in New York during World
War two since then we understand you've
been with the international refugee
organization in Austria and have watched
our foreign policy work at close range
firsthand I wonder could you tell us as
a close observer is our marshal plan and
our foreign policy being administered
wisely in Europe well sir I can't course
speak as an expert because I've been
in Europe too long but I have been close
to it for five years to all the
developments in Austria and formerly in
Germany well do you believe that we
ended the Marshall Plan program to
assume that we see the on the economies
of civilian economies under countries
affected Marshall client funds made
possible tremendous improvement in the
European economy where we stand that's
it and that the standard of living
improved I think the changeover to the
to the direct two or more direct
military expenditures and they lessening
of the the increase of prices during the
Korean War and also the perhaps the
lessening of the funds spent as has
created difficulties among well dr.
relation of Europe Roger feel sir that
they creation of military expenses in
Europe by the United States was
necessary I think is I think any any
steps taken to improve our defenses or
necessary I think that we perhaps are a
little more frantic and friends in our
our apprehensions about Russia then we
need to be I don't think the Russians
are going to make direct military moves
in West Europe I never have thought so
all the time I've been there why are we
building an army there I think the
purpose of our
defenses in Europe is to bolster their
strength and to harden them and to to
increase their spirit of resistance and
it may be that those things are useful
general would you of course are aware
the fact you've been out of the country
a long time but this is an election year
and it's a particularly important
election year to our people and our
listeners are sort of searching their
souls to see whether we have spent too
much now and you're whether we are
overreaching ourselves as a nation now
in your opinion sir we as a nation can
take some pride in satisfaction in our
Marshall planned expenditures you've
said that that's been a proper thing and
that our nation can be proud of those
interviews all of its land that we have
by and large gotten some value received
for it I'm sure now you are making a
difference between that and our present
military expenditures now in general do
you think that perhaps this year we are
trying to spend more than we should in
Europe on military affairs I believe
that we could take a much calmer view of
the whole situation in a longer range
view and put the economic basis of
opposition to Russia before the military
I see now in your view you're saying it
that we can take a longer view so that
means that you don't think that war is
imminent I don't think war is imminent
and I have not thought so for five years
do you think that it's the Russian plan
to try to weaken us economically rather
than to attack that's my belief and that
it's a very long range plan and that we
must plan accordingly right if that's
the Russian plan over a period of years
and it may be 10 20 wheels we have since
that's the Russian plan is to attack us
economically make us weak then our first
consideration in your view should be to
protect ourselves from that follow from
economic derangement at home
feel that we must keep ourselves strong
and by that I mean economically and to
keep our morale I well I gather from
what you say general that you believe
Russia is winning her campaign against
us if she thinking us yeah I think I
don't know you know more about what is
being done to us economically than I do
I haven't been here very long well you
just paid your taxes but lacks is and
the general feelings that I sense of
apprehension and the and doubt and
confusion here lead me to believe that
Russia may be succeeding and actually
Russia has succeeded in taking a large
part of the population the world without
losing them a man do you believe that
the the people of Europe are as
necessary to us militarily as we have
led them to believe I think we should
change our emphasis and in from
enlightened self-interest to sort of an
inquiring self-interest and I don't
believe that the people of Europe or in
the long run essential to the existence
of the United State we can get along
without them in your view I think we
should do everything we could to bolster
them to strengthen them and within our
possibilities I don't believe finally
that the security of the United States
wrists anywhere but in our own hands a
general you of course sir have a
reputation as a great fighting soldier
both with our own Armas and I believe
you went to the Col de guerre you were
you also know something about the
fighting abilities of other nations
having fought two wars in Europe I'm
sure that our audience would like some
quick evaluations from you as to what
you think we're getting for our dollar
in the form of fighting arm is now do
you think that the the French for
instance are in a mood to fight now and
if we can create a fighting force in
France I think the French your ad
soldiers I've seen them in battle I've
seen
in time of war
making greatest of sacrifices I believe
that they are that their pride lies in
their nation and I am quite doubtful
about the value of the of the army
that's being created on a basis merely
of formulas and in a European same a
night at european army I don't believe
it has any great value know what about
the Germans do you think that our
efforts to create to invite the Germans
to join an international force might be
successful I think the Germans are great
soldiers I don't believe that the
Germans are either are going to to be
willing to fight for for a divided
Germany you think that then that we that
our efforts to create an international
fighting force in Europe might not be as
successful as we had hoped i think the
steps that we're taking may be
successful in time but i think it'll be
a very long range thing they take
generations the meantime you would spend
the money for something else i would
spend the money where it would
strengthen us most well now see we've
had on our show we've had a number of
Americans who have said that we must
plan for at least a 15 year period of
making our nation strong in which a
large proportion of our nice and
expenditures must go to arms now is it
your view that we should take a
long-range view and should make our own
nation strong and most of our money
should be spent on our own armaments it
in my view
must rely on ourselves finally for our
security if we take a calm of view of
the whole thing if we can watch our own
expenditures and find out how much we
can afford then in my opinion we must
gauge our efforts to that economically
can we just cut ourselves off from the
rest of the world well I don't think so
but I mean if we can avoid it no but in
my opinion in the long run we can exist
no matter we have them no matter who has
any particular I'll general I'm sure
that our audience would like to have
your view on this if were should come to
worst and if our nation in this
generation should have to fight the
Russian power complex you believe that
we as a nation still have the strength
to build a fighting army that could deal
successfully with the Russians I do i do
we dealt with the Germans when they had
all of Europe we dealt with the Japanese
when they had all of the Pacific well
general I'm sure that our audience is
understood your message tonight and that
is that you think that our emphasis
should be on making our own nation
strong militarily thank you very much
for being with us tonight certainly the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn jeene ko no scope was mister
william bradford huie and mr. Donald I
Rogers our distinguished guests was
general john s would former chief of
mission of the international refugee
organization